welcome to my pretend living room where
we're going to play sword coast legends
a joint venture between digital extremes
and in space we have on the stream with
us you can't see them because they're
all joining us through skype ash Sevilla
and over in the gamespot office
Marrakech and Eric Tay and I'm Justin
hey walled well and let's just jump into
the game so ash one of the unique things
about Sword Coast legends here is that
there's a dungeon master mode and that
we're actually playing a campaign that
you yourself have created right yeah
this is a campaign I created called
burning Don trials part 1 and it's
designed to be an introduction to the
game and it's it's a fun way to just to
run around and learn some of the
controls and what some of the systems
are like and what's your role in the
development of the game you don't just
sit around making modules all day I
assume that would be an amazing role of
such a thing existed I'm actually the
community manager and the development
coordinator so I do a lot of everything
which is I'm the everything guy and so
the dungeon master mode lets anybody
create a full Dungeons and Dragons
campaign so i think it's worth
mentioning shortcodes legends has the
full backing of wizards of the coast
this is a real Dungeons and Dragons game
set in the Forgotten Realms setting
right yeah absolutely we've been working
with wizards of the coast since day one
and obviously we were on the phone with
them on a regular basis and you know we
have their full blessing with a product
and it's it's been a lot of fun you know
it's a great world to play in and we
can't wait to see you know what people
are going to create so I look forward to
seeing what you've set up for us how do
we do we go over into this book here to
get started yeah so this is a little an
NPC it'll start you out and everyone
won't be able to read his text here I'll
let you guys read that but you know as a
dungeon master you're able to create all
your own NPCs you design them from the
ground up you can dress them you can
give them personalities you can you know
give them exposition like boom are here
and all boom are here is really showing
you guys where to go next so he's
basically telling you hey like this is
the beginning of your quest I'm gonna
send you on the next leg of it and he's
just kind of showing you the the early
early ropes of the game mm-hmm
and this is kind of muddled after it
looks like you know baldur's gate and
neverwinter nights the classic dungeons
and dragons games that I know I played
growing up but it seems like the
creation tool is a lot simpler than than
it was back then yeah we we kind of set
out from the very beginning to design it
to be accessible but at the same time
really deep if you if you want to get
that deep with that we've already had
people that have made campaigns that are
10-plus hours long I'm the one you guys
are me playing today is you know it can
be done in about three hours but it's
really up to the dungeon master how long
he wants to actually make his or her
module so it can get it can get pretty
in depth all right so will I guess go
over the world travel chef india fourth
yeah and then you guys will get to
choose probably there should only be one
location open to you guys right now but
if i wanted to as a dungeon master i
could you know put quests all over this
little opening map and let you guys jump
to wherever you'd like to go but for now
I think you guys only have one spot hmm
uh i'm actually not seeing it I'm so I
see the adventurers camp that was
burning down camp right yeah burning
down camp is where you guys should go
there we go just canceled yet into it
sorry as a DM you can actually write all
these loading screens as well so you can
kind of give your players a little bit
of a background about where they're
headed or you know write a riddle or do
whatever you want there so so you've
written all this yourself this is not
something you've pulled from some other
source yeah this is all this is all
stuff I wrote on one of my days off just
to kind of have fun with module making
and hello again looks like I beat you
here curious about how this camp is set
up and who really runs the show someone
was kind enough to etch some information
in the stone behind me we accept
so what was your inspiration for this
particular creation well this is sort of
so in the primary campaign you actually
play as a member of the burning dawn
which is sort of a ragtag guild that's
been around for about a hundred years in
the Forgotten Realms and during the
campaign they fall upon some hard times
and so I kind of wanted to show the
burning dawn before everything started
to go badly so some of the NPC's you're
talking to now actually do appear in
this story so this is sort of a
headcanon ashes headcanon prequel to the
actual campaign of the game so I I just
wanted to do it for fun because I really
fell in love with the characters and I
wanted to show you know what some of the
tools are capable of and the setting in
the back of all of the the set dressing
as well that you've got to play setters
they're kind of a preset map that you
put this into well the maps are preset
there's a you know many many different
ones to choose from of different sizes
but everything that the audience is
looking at right now from the tables to
the fire there to the you know the
crates in the bushes and and the way
that those NPC looks the tents all of
that is stuff that I placed and when you
guys are done like reading through the
question such if you hold down your alt
key you can actually see some of the
items that are highlighted ball and
you'll actually be able to read a little
bit about you know what's on the dinner
table or what's inside that crate over
there so all those things are things
that the dungeon master can actually you
know dress up and write so she has we
click on the table that says Gill has
prepared a fine meal for order members
perhaps one day you'll be invited to eat
how long did it take you to put all this
together this seems really in-depth this
one took me I don't say maybe about
three or four hours to do but I've been
messing with the tools for a long time I
think if you're learning the tools
they'll take a little while to get the
hang of we've we've heard you know that
some people during her head start
programs was spent twenty plus hours on
their campaigns and they're all
available for for download which is
really cool so once you jump in there
you can just check and see you know
which which modules are highly rated and
go ahead and download those and try them
out yourself so that you know there's
really it's pretty awesome there's
unlimited adventures if you're into this
kind of thing
alright so see you're gonna go for okay
so the first place you guys should
definitely go to if you picked up those
all this quest you should probably go to
layer of the rat clean first which is
you guys will be researching why this
rodent population in a nearby town is
gone amok and they're basically going
absolutely absolutely crazy eating all
sorts of livestock in all sorts of all
sorts of people as well and so you go
into this this underground lair to
discover what's going on with these with
these rodents so we didn't show the
character creation before we we all got
into this we create our own characters
and there's a lot of customization both
in terms of how your character looks and
their abilities yeah there's a lot you
can do there's a lot of different you
know you can choose from a lot of the
classic Forgotten Realms races and
classes one of the cool things I'm doing
now is I'm actually controlling this
group of rodents right here so I can
take you know one of these rats and I
can go I can go after Mary back there I
want these rats to go after her so I can
I can do all sorts of really fun stuff
as a dungeon master i can directly
control them I can lay down traps I can
do all sorts of things there's also if
you if you do a search or if you hold
down the Alt key you can see that
there's a little bit of information and
exposition on these skeletons here you
can say oh you know these these bones
have been picked clean or you can write
really whatever you want for your
players so I'm dying one yes so with the
rules for this based on the most recent
version of dragons game yeah so the
rules are based on 5th edition D&D and
obviously you know there has to be a bit
of modification for for you know a real
time experience especially for with one
real time experience so it is a modified
version of 5th edition but that was very
much the basis of where we you know
where we came up with our rule set
now if you want to help you want to help
justina up you just go up and left click
and you'll stabilize cement that'll
actually get them up I'm a glass cannon
wizard ing so there's lots of different
stuff I can do here as a DM so I'm gonna
give you a bit of a warning i'm actually
gonna add an explosive trap to this door
in real time and i'm going to make a
little bit challenging to find so you
might see it you might not see it you
might be able to disarm it we'll see if
you sarmet you a little bit of
experience you get to move on and again
this is just an introductory module so
that's why you guys are fighting the
staple rats in the beginning now if I
wanted to be a challenge it add extra
features here I can make them attack
from a different angle I could do all
sorts of different stuff and you're
doing that all on the fly like as you're
watching right leg you have complete
control right so I'll for instance I
have some zombies here at my disposal so
even though it's not actually part of
the story I'm just gonna make some
zombies appear just to fight you guys
cuz he doesn't love zombies right take
them down
and then if you don't want to do
anything like if you're just a DN who
wanted to set up this dungeon but not be
micromanaging every little thing they're
still gonna you know attack on their own
and act of their own accord right yeah
absolutely so you can set up your module
to have you know real-time interaction
or to just run on it so actually all
modules will run on their own without a
live DM but live dming is kind of fun we
can do all sorts of you know fun
role-playing activities like you know I
can make you guys do a role check or you
know our perception check I can do all
sorts of different things in real time
that would be challenging to do without
a live I don't know go away go up so one
of the cool things you can do I'm going
to pause and tell you how guys how to do
this you guys should see an empty player
portrait because we don't have a fourth
player now if you want to bring in a
fourth player as an npc you can actually
do that so if you click that blank
player portrait once I unpause you can
actually bring in one of the NPC's from
the story I suggest you bring in a
cleric I'll go ahead and do that adding
a fourth player increase the difficulty
of the things you fight so what it
actually does is our system takes the
average player level and creates
creatures based on that player level so
it'll actually average all your levels
and that's what level the the monsters
will be so it's not gonna really
increase the the overall difficulty it
should just still average everything as
you wish
and they over so when you're playing the
game normally you're actually also able
to pause the action and it kind of do a
turn-based deciding what actions you
want to take it or the players able to
do that when you're in this motor is
that just the DM actually you can you
can set it up either way so you when you
actually set up the the particular
dungeon you can have it so players are
able to pause you know it's really up to
the group playing like if you're playing
with a bunch of your close friends and
you trust them to have you know that
power to just pause all the time then we
let you do that so it's totally an
option for players and dungeon masters
and so we know where you're at because
you're this floating purple you see my
purple wispy huh yeah so I guess it'll
be a little bit scary when you leave
where we're at because that means that
you're in some other part of the dungeon
possibly setting up something horrible
that will happen to us that's that is
absolutely correct right away and so is
his name coming into this we had the
story elements that were set up are you
able to to add any of that or change the
story on the fly as well yeah actually
um there's all sorts of things we can do
here I'll do something order to uh to
give you a little bit of a D&D flavor so
these guys a little bit more challenging
it's like a Lydia's helping you out
there alright so I'll do a little a
little DM action for you guys here so as
you guys actually approach this entryway
you notice that a bunch of large rocks
have slid down and are actually blocking
the entrance they're a little too tall
to climb over but it seems as though
maybe one of you might be strong enough
to move the rocks out of the way so if
you want to walk up to longer away and
do it strength check i'll show you how
to do that do that okay all right so if
you look in the bottom left there's a
little a little toggle right there that
you can click on that opens up like a
chat window mm-hmm and if you type in
four slash roll one d20 you like to be
able to do a a roll check there and so
we're gonna do a little strength check
to see if you guys can move these rocks
I won't tell you the difficulty of
moving the rocks but so everyone should
give it a shot forward slash roll one
d20 and see if you can actually move
those rocks out of the way if not I'll
make something terrible happen to you so
I got a strength check of 14 so then you
know that's very much like sitting
around with your friends played like an
experience that you typically only get
around the table I don't think was a
part of the the other baldur's gate
leave the games that we had growing up
yeah I mean it's interesting where you
know we're finding new ways to to
implement skill checks and things like
that that we that players are really
clamoring for so the fact that you
rolled pretty high on your strength
check means i can remove this and say
you know I'll just pause it and say okay
you're able to actually move the rocks
out of the way and continue on your
adventure nothing bad happens so you can
do all sorts of you know fun things like
that it's Dungeon Master live in real
time you can have you know you can have
you know dexterity checks you can do all
sorts of really really fun stuff that
they do on the tabletop I want to point
out that maybe you can't read that if
you're watching this on the stream but
they put the slash backwards because he
does not understand how keyboards work
like but who does forward slash for what
I did I did the other way to it didn't
work so I tried both ways borough
oh we don't have weed on PvP yet guys
and so this is an III don't think you're
not calling it early access but people
are able to get into the game right now
and in creepies dungeons play some of
the the single-player campaign yeah so
we're doing these headstart weekends for
people that pre-order and you know we're
looking at a lot of feedback from these
headstart weekend and really kind of
enjoying working with the community to
come up with some neat and interesting
things and people are playing the ways
the game in different ways than we were
really expecting so it's been it's been
a big learning experience and it's been
a lot of fun too because people are
already generating really incredible
content just a few weeks in so what in
particular is really stood out as
surprising or they didn't expect for
people to do well um people have been
finding ways to players have really
found ways to min max their characters
and to really level up very very quickly
and you know I play I'm really
old-fashioned so I play very naturally
and I take my time and and Pete players
are finding ways to just blow through
things and find you know the modules
that will yield the most experience and
how to you know get the best weapons as
quickly as they can so part of it was
mainly you know us I don't want to say
being naive with us being like you know
thinking people were gonna play like we
play but um but you know obviously when
you get thousands and thousands people
playing they're gonna have all sorts of
different play styles so that was kind
of a learning experience for us I can do
that we survived once and so we've
touched on this a little bit bein you've
mentioned it that there's also a
complete single-player campaign it's not
like this is just a create your own
dungeon multiplayer kind of experience
right right um Oh
Oh employees in there I know that's bad
yeah so there is a whole a whole full
campaign that's 40 plus hours you know I
absolutely love it has some really great
companion some really you know it's a
really memorable adventure and I know
that's kind of hard there's so many RPGs
with great stories these days I think
the thing that really makes scl stand
out is the fact that you can actually
play through the whole campaign
experience the whole story but you can
actually do it with up to three other
players so you can do the whole campaign
with your buddies which is great be
strong and for those creation tools for
for you know making your own dungeons it
sounded like the characters that you
meet the characters they're able to add
to your party or is something that's
unlocked as you play along but for the
rest of the creation tools do you have
just full access to the entire suite to
everything from the start yes so there's
actually at this point the way that is
set up is uh nothing's really locked out
so once you get control of the DM tools
you'll have access to everything the
things that we are like you said you can
only bring in companions that you meet
in the campaign so if you want to
actually bring in additional companions
you'll have to experience the campaign
to actually add them to your roster and
there's a I think we've revealed eight
so far so we have eight different
companions in the main story all very
different all you know with great
personalities and really fun to play as
what's your favorite companion so far
I'm actually a big fan of the one you
brought in a Lydia she's uh she's a moon
elf but she you guys are just blowing
everything up she's a moon elf but she's
she's a cleric but she uses a bow
because that's one of the the racial
abilities in 5th edition that moon elves
can actually use bows so she attacks
from range but at the same time she's
just great versatility great character
she has a really cool backstory which
you'll learn about as you play and you
guys are just we're doing really well
with these perhaps you went through the
toxic explosion traps here so as the DM
are you able to so theatre we've been
able to bring our characters back to
life multiple
are you able to set that as a rule as
well or no right now they're the only
penalty if the whole party wipes you'll
actually start back at the beginning of
the dungeon there is no big death
penalty other than that so you know in
5th edition D&D they use stabilized to
bring characters back from the brink of
death and that's kind of the system we
went with so you're not going to see
wounds you're not going to see you know
characters limping or anything like that
so right now stabilized is what we're
going with and it works pretty well I
mean you'll you'll get pretty good at
bringing the characters back and you
know in the thick of battle and it gets
pretty challenging a harder level so and
that's how it works in the single-player
campaign as well yeah yeah that's the
way it works there as well you guys are
using your search ability and so using
search will ostensibly help us find a
trap before it comes out right yeah so
players have like an active perception
which is based on their wisdom score so
just determines how well they see you
know the environment around them but if
you turn your search on you guys will
notice that you'll you'll slow down a
bit but at the same time it actually
raises your act of perception so it's a
great way to find traps it's a great way
to you know make sure that you don't
step on a bunch of giant poison bombs
like you guys did yeah I don't have that
ability so you two need to step it up
yeah sorry Tay you're the you're the
tank you're there to take the damage for
us
it'll prompt you and you can disarm them
or you just avoid them you can you can
do either or so if you really want to
i'm gonna pause it because i want to
tell you guys a little story as you go
over the bridge but yeah you can um you
can choose to disarm the traps you'll
get an experience bonus or you can just
walk around them and try not to step on
them so alright so as you guys enter
this room across the bridge you see a
horde of the undead that are slowly
making their way toward you oh that's a
that's a lot destroy the bridge yeah are
you are you able to add in elements like
that that lets you kind of maybe play
around with the expectations of the the
DM maybe doing things the DM wouldn't
expect like jump up on a table or
destroy a bridge instead of just
fighting uh we don't have destructible
environments right now but there's a lot
of stuff you can cheat like for instance
I was just gonna say that as they're
walking across the bridge the the rumble
from their footsteps makes the rocks
behind you slide and the entryway that
you came through is now blocked so you
can do stuff like that you can't blow up
the bridge and block progress but there
are barriers and things like that you
can place and and all is it all sorts of
there's hundreds of different place
ballabh Jex so you can do all sorts of
things to dress up an area to tell a
story
so but you you would have the ability to
maybe just like throw down rocks on the
middle of the bridge and say like there
was a landslide here and now to get over
you have to roll the dexterity check to
climb over them or something like that
absolutely I I did one behind you guys
but if I wanted to I could just throw
one down you know in front of this
doorway um heck let's do it don't crush
let's do it let's let's go ahead and put
some barriers in front of you and we're
gonna make you jump over them see what
you did to yourselves okay so as I do I
want you guys to do a quick decks check
do a forward slash roll 1d 20 and we'll
see which one of you guys can actually
get over this oh boy good 12 take out of
12 I got a 9 their fur so when you have
a non-playable character when you have a
guy that's just joined like our cleric
how does that work or do you just kind
of I you would have to at that point
you'd have to kind of cheat the system
or you can roll for that character so I
know it yeah and also you know if you're
playing by real 5th edition rules you
would have oh look at that 14 all right
so um so Mary actually does make it over
and she's able to assist you guys from
the other side and you guys are actually
able to get past the wall but you hear
something terrible like a screeching
coming from coming from the distance you
don't know what it is but it sounds like
something something you know hideous and
and other other earthly probably
and so I feel like this would uh this
would let you do things like you
wouldn't a D&D campaign where it's like
instead of maybe rushing in the battle
you could say like oh I want to do a a
check to see what kind of danger is
ahead of me and then that would allow
you to to change the difficulty on the
fly or change what kind of things are
going to experience right that's what
we're really really hoping people do I
mean it's very easy just get in here and
you know click things and not really you
know pay attention to what you're doing
but if you really want to role play and
you really want to have a good time you
know the players can say like you know I
want to check my surroundings and the DM
can react accordingly you know I can
make it an encounter more difficult or
or easier based on you know what based
on what you guys are saying to me so and
so does the progress that you make when
you're in these modules can that carry
over to the single player as well yes so
your character is your character I'll
you killed the rat Queen very quickly
yeah your progress actually carries over
so you can um you can jump up from the
player campaign to different modules and
then jump back to the player campaign or
whatever DLC is coming out and still use
the same character the whole time so and
so of course we got some experience from
that do we get do we get loot do you
decide what the loot is what the rewards
are for that um actually right now
what's happening with loot is it is it's
a random system so you guys should
receive rewards like quest rewards
inside your bags individually but then
these chests will actually have random
items inside them as well so it'll be up
to you to kind of distribute the things
that you find and we did that because
you know some players love it some
players don't love it but we did that so
that people will be encouraged to kind
of keep adventuring keep it going on
different quests to find those items
that they really want we were kind of
afraid that if we just gave dm's the
power to place whatever object they
would want to place and in terms of loot
that they would just build entire levels
filled with epic swords and that would
kind of it and it kind of deter people
from going on those adventures so right
now it's it's a random system but we'll
see how people like it yeah that would
definitely change the balance of the
game right it's tricky because you know
we want people to have all
that power is the D am but at the same
time you want people to you know go on
adventures with their friends and get
really excited when they find something
that they haven't seen before so I would
abused it right yeah right yeah it's
challenging because we have dev tools
and we can just summon whatever weapons
we want is really hard not to do it well
thanks so much for taking us through
this early part of the campaign I I
don't want to spoil too much the game is
coming out really soon actually the
October 20th i think on pc and mac right
yeah absolutely october 20th pc mac in
2016 for ps4 and xbox one and head
starts are actually starting this friday
and they'll continue right up until
launch on and off so definitely check
check our social sites to see when the
head starts are happening but and it
feels natural to play on keyboard and
mouse does the pc version also support
controller yeah so it does and we're
working on we're working on refining
controller support later on for 4
consoles and buffing it up on the pc
side as well really exciting stuff and
again ash thanks so much for walking us
through hey I'm sorry that I'm a bad
wizard and Mary good job you loved
running on the front lines is the wizard
let's think about that I know why did I
keep I was just pushing forward the
entire time that is not the role of the
wizard hey guys that was fun let me know
if you guys ever want to play will play
you